we are joined Now by Chief Washington
correspondent Major Garrett good morning
major you were there at Mar-A-Lago in
the room
um tell us what it was like and we
should remind our viewers you've been in
that room a lot you've seen a lot of
moments like this how does it compare
so it was a very odd situation John you
wouldn't normally expect on a day as
historic as yesterday was there's no
other way to describe yesterday first
time this country has gone through the
trauma of watching a former president
come before the court as a defendant
indicted on a series of felonies you
might think the atmosphere reflecting
that of the former president inside that
courtroom would be somber it was
anything but somber it was festive
people were cradling glasses of wine in
martinis and beer glasses and drinking
water
the music was upbeat the attitude was
entirely supportive and almost strangely
jubilant until the former president got
there yes there were lots of Applause
for him but when he started speaking and
gave what is to buy now for many Trump
supporters and all too familiar speech
with a laundry list of grievances legal
and political the room kind of died down
and became much less energized than
before the former president came in so
if last night's goal was to draw energy
from that crowd fortify the former
president for this legal battle to come
by my estimation having been in that
room and been to lots of places where
Trump has energized the crowd had been
energized and kind back it just didn't
work
and major you have covered this uh form
this president for a long time former
president
given what you saw last night and
knowing he's also running a presidential
campaign what are you hearing from
fellow Republicans now and possibly
those who might be running against him
now that the indictment and all of these
charges had been released to the public
so the great question for Republicans
who are concerned about the party's
future generally and who are thinking
about possibly running against former
president Trump is this
will these charges wear well will the
idea that the former president is a
victim that the prosecutor in Manhattan
is unhinged and bringing a weak case
just because he wants to do it for his
own Ambitions or ego or because he made
some kind of vague campaign promise a
lot of Republicans are comfortable
staying in that lane the crime is out of
control in Manhattan and this prosecutor
is taking his eye off that ball they're
okay there but they don't know if this
is going to wear well over time
or they also don't know what's going to
happen with the investigation in Fulton
County Georgia or the investigation in
Washington D.C about what president
Trump did or didn't do with classified
documents what were his actions up to
and on January 6th all of those things
create not just legal uncertainty for
the former president but great political
uncertainty for everyone trying to gauge
just how powerful he's going to remain
as the current front-runner in the
Republican Party nomination battle for
2024.
major Trump has been known to use
inflammatory rhetoric but given the
warning by the judge do you believe that
his posture will change or do you think
that he might turn it up a notch
well look listen to what the former
president's lawyer said yesterday they
said the truck the judge didn't warn him
he just said everyone should be calm and
relaxed and not use inflammatory
language and they even said the former
president hasn't used inflammatory
language so if the lawyers are defending
the former president you can bet the
former president that is to say Trump
will be aggressive in his own defense
and volatile in this language about
what's going on just this morning on his
truth social platform he said
republicans in Congress should defund
the entire department of justice and the
FBI essentially defanging all federal
investigatory law enforcement entirely
why because he's a victim again back to
the original question will that wear
well politically or legally right now
that's where the former president is
we'll see if he's there two or three
months from now yeah to be continued
Major Garrett thank you so much